mit ihrem einsatz belieben wir kultur
swisslos lusti fertigen
[Musik]
willkommen h einkultur platz ja
normalerweise herrscht zu dieser zeit im
jahr in solothurn reges treiben in
klirrender kälte
[Musik]
aus
die filmtage sind so etwas wie das
wärmende lagerfeuer an dem sich die
filmbranche einmal im jahr trifft sich
austauscht und sich feiert all das war
dieses jahr nicht möglich und konnte
doch stattfinden einfach ganz anders
dazu der bericht meiner kollegin sandra
stefan januar kälte wie immer an den
filmtagen
doch dieses jahr friere ich nicht ich
sitze in der warmen stube und coupé die
eröffnung gemütlich an fernsehern die
traditionsreiche werkschau des schweizer
films kommt zu mir nach hause schön
inszeniert aber wenig sie überhaupt
daheim haben
ich vermisse das muntere wuseln auf dem
roten teppich
das nervöse stelldichein der
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler und
die gespannte vorfreude auf dem
eröffnungsfilm
[Musik]
die harten holzstühlen der reithalle
tausche ich allerdings gerne 1 gegen ein
weiches sofa aber die bundesrätliche
rede kommt allein daheim geschaut
doppelt trocken daher unsichtbar ist
auch meine akkreditierung die bei den
jockeys landet statt eines film passes
gibt's ein passwort kkh 3298 das werde
ich mir niemals merken können das
online-angebot auf der website ist
riesig 211 filme darunter 36 probieren
und rund 100 veranstaltungen
filmgespräche podiumsdiskussion
wer soll das alles schauen mich packt
die nostalgie stadt in die virtuelle
welt einzutauchen würde ich jetzt lieber
die klimatisch etwas unterkühlte aber
gesellige solothurn atmosphäre genießen
den legendären geist von solothurn den
bringt ein komiker auf den punkt indem
ihr einen deutschschweizer regisseur
parodiert blieben sie in den smoking die
klammer die bling bling ebenso glamour
frei lasse ich mich daheim dann doch auf
das online erlebnis ein und entdecke
perlen beeindruckend die ängste der
extremsportlerin rühren die nöte des
homosexuellen türken beängstigend und
faszinierend die entwicklung der
künstlichen intelligenz dennoch sehne
ich mich nach dem dunklen kinosaal dem
sinnlichen erlebnis und nach
störungsfrei im filmgenuss
mir fehlt das pralle leben solothurn ist
seit jahrzehnten nicht nur der ort zum
filmegucken man will auch darüber reden
in der beiz treffen sich jeweils
filmemacher publikum und journalisten
zum diskutieren essen trinken und bei
mir daheim filmgespräch im live stream
das findet zu einem für mich
unmenschlichen zeitpunkt statt
samstagmorgen aber der dokumentarfilm
hat mich gepackt
darin geht es um die angst in ihren
unterschiedlichsten formen bei evelyne
binsack ist sie sehr konkret die
abenteurerin ist allein in der arktis
unterwegs und filmt dabei sich selbst
bleiben
ich klicke mich ein ins gespräch
zwischen filmtage die rektorin anita
hobby und regisseurin miriam fuchs und
schaffe es interaktiv eine frage zu
stellen können sie nun selbst besser mit
angst umgehen
das interaktive angebot wird allerdings
nicht eben regel genutzt
meine frage bleibt die einzige aber ich
glaube ich habe ich habe wieder ein
bisschen mehr gelassenheit gefunden
auch ich bin gelassener geworden und
gewöhne mich allmählich ans kino im
taschenformat das mich im alltag
begleitet ich bin froh dass die filmtage
das online experiment gewagt haben und
nicht trotz geschlossener kinos tolle
filme entdecken ließen
und doch mehr als eine notlösung sollte
das bitte nicht sein
[Musik]
analyst
andernorts ist ein
[Musik]
anita da ist was für ihre rezepte wie
die kultur von österreich darum sie
immer wenn du du als direktorin da in
solothurn kotz die sich so still da ja
es ist sehr still übrigens so sehr viel
schnee dass das natürlich zu busfahrer
bisher die trage bereits kinofilm
gespräche stattfinden jetzt die letzten
mittwoch und das ist ein ganz tolles
stimmig trotzdem obwohl sich rhetorik
ist und normalerweise würde natürlich
hier wachsen woche
jetzt haben wir die online edition also
die größte busflotte geschenk ich
gesehen dass er wird dort sachlicher
dynamische situation ist dass auch die
situation wirklich mein geschmack leicht
verändert müssen bis die herbst- oder
verstanden dass man hier vor ort oder
schürt natürlich wirklich inneren form
eine schutzmaßnahme und aber gerechnet
vorbereitet und mit bezeugt allem haben
wir sie nicht dass wir das hier vor ort
nicht weiterführen und hätte vor dem
spiel bei online festival ist stand bei
online festival über gewechselt und
deshalb die mieten sind nicht überrascht
es sie dass man jetzt online festivals
stattfinden
trotzdem lasse dass die verweigerer
stichwort enorme wie hieß es dazu lösung
für die filmschaffenden und zwar um auge
zahn tisch sehr wichtig sie das mit
einer neuen situation aber nur lose sind
für den leitungsbau in filmen und da
jetzt im dialog aller neue folgen
zusammen definieren wie man das etwa
dafür dass heißt ein sogenannter
solidaritätsbeitrag aufgrund verdammt
die ganze firmen gestellt
ich kann man hat jetzt sich langfristig
und da man sich so mit der beteiligung
sicheres novum in der festivallandschaft
dass mir das so dass er machen und das
ist ja dass man füreinander bedürfnis
gremium zusammen ist für die schweizer
firma vom publikum sehr gut an
ohne das auge bot oder grenzt noch nie
naja also tut sie extrem glücklich und
froh um eine riesige zuspruch man hätte
für langjährige besucherinnen und
besucher wo ich schreibe sich super
siegen natürlich tage lang läuft unter
mobile sie filme wie übrigens sehr viele
theologen was sie normalerweise vor ort
überlegen wo sie sich auch selbst wieder
was ich im auge die filme gesehen was
ich meinen geschichten und bildern
handle
mai noch keine zahlung ist auch
intendanz und zu sprechen wie vor sitzt
ruft zu fahren ist ein mögliches kennt
[Musik]
bei den solothurner filmtagen laufen
dieses jahr im wettbewerb gleich zwei
filme über kämpfende frauen die
dokumentationen stellen die frage
weshalb dieses thema noch immer für so
viel aufsehen sorgt und sie vertreten
die these dies baldmöglichst zu ändern
[Musik]
die protagonisten von alle ist 19 jahre
alt als sie mit dem wrestling begins
wrestling das ist eine schweißtreibende
mischung aus show krank und kampfsport
der dokumentarfilm begleitet alexandra
ein jahr lang zeigt ihr hartes training
die vorbereitung auf erste wettkämpfe
aller ist eine der wenigen frauen in
ihrem wrestling club die männer im
training nehmen sie zwar gut auf für ihr
umfeld sei es aber ungewohnt gewesen als
sie mit kampfsport begonnen habe sagt
alexandra do boullier heute-show krieg
sie sowohl mit kants von fernseh
zuschauer 8 brutal webber dass das bild
so
eigentlich wollte regisseur und libero
tzscherlich einfach einen film über den
riesling sport machen
[Musik]
doch als er seine protagonistin gefunden
hatte wurde ihm klar indem er eine frau
begleitet die kampfsport betreibt gewinn
sein film eine weitere ebene nicht mit
dem projekt angefangen habe ich nicht
bewusst würde eine feministische film
mache in erster linie ist es ein
dokumentarischer coming of age film aus
der perspektive foto alessandra erzählt
aber dieses jahr weniger frau wrestling
ausführen ich muss mir auch bewusst dass
ich haben müsse die die die
feministische ansicht aus der sicht von
der alexander thematisieren
gerade in solchen momenten konnte film
seiner protagonistin serie zeigt auch
ihre inneren kämpfe ich kann man nun
frau vom amerikanischen wrestling
ich bin nicht so frau
wir sind und die dünn und zerbrechlich
ich finde
bis 9 ich bin dass er sich also vater
hat mir dann sagen ich mach nicht klare
sache
nachdem wie auf den worten das ist auch
erster thema beim öffnen
auch die bremsen
kämpfende frauen sind noch immer nicht
alltäglich wie das boxen in der schweiz
zeigt
im jahr 2009 10 betrug der frauenanteil
im lizenzierten boxsport grimma 13
prozent
den frauen fehlt es an vorbildern an den
olympischen spielen wurde boxen als
disziplin für frauen erst im jahr 2012
zugelassen
monika hofmann arbeitet im zentrum für
geschlechterforschung der universität
bern und ist punkt sowie ringrichter
haye boxen
sie sagt damit mehr für kampfsport
betreiben müssten sich zuerst die
geschlechterbilder in der gesellschaft
ändern kann sie immer noch sehr aber
mangels kommentiert vorraum fust kampf
das ist glaube immer noch bis wo frau
nicht so lehrer im labor aus mettmann
jannik förderteam sich hofer mit china
bei der galashow also junge bürger das
ist das motto kraft und home
entertainment großer geburt um vorsicht
orange werde ich kämpfen sagt liefern
sie auch in amazon in einer großstadt
geht es um kämpferinnen
die doku läuft ebenfalls an den
solothurner filmtagen sie begleitet
frauen mit den unterschiedlichsten
hintergründen
sie alle stehen für etwas ein das ihnen
wichtig ist selbst bestimmt für
regisseurin teils odermatt ein
herzensprojekt amazone frei wo einfach
kämpft für die gedacht für die sache für
jedes labor das ist so einfach wie sie
sich das vorstellt und das ist
vielleicht der kompromisslos aber gleich
mit mit einer gewissen humor und mit dem
nicht viel besser sondern einfach nur
positive krampf teils odermatt
patentierten ihrem film unter anderem
eine ehemalige kurdische
freiheitskämpferin einen weiblichen dj
oder einen mixed martial arts weiterhin
in den mixed martial arts kurz ist
vieles erlaubt das im wrestling oder
boxen verboten ist auch in diesem sport
sind die frauen in der unterzahl
viele der selbsternannten amazonen
empfehlen
haben damit zu kämpfen dass sie von
männern sexualisiert werden
das ist der regisseurin auch bei der
vorbereitung des films aufgefallen
amazon ist also über sexualisiert und
ist eine man fantasie und ich glaube sie
sich der blick vom mitmachen wolle
hoffentlich schaffen um rasch den ruf
sondern was ich eine frage erfordert
warum das sie klang kämpfen nicht nur
körperlich sondern auch im übertragenen
sinn für mehr anerkennung mehr rechte
mehr freiheit für diese alltäglichen
kämpfe kann das sport ebenfalls ein
gutes training sein
merlin keller oder begegnet man muss die
analysiere ich überlege zloty begriff ja
wie ich mir die verteidigung und ich
glaube die sache die spiele im
kampfsport euro aber ein normaler
kampfsituationen wenn man sich überlegt
wenn man verkrampft 36 sexismus oder
gleichberechtigung dass man über lady
gagas kampf mit wählen damit so gar
nicht vor
wo bin ich mit ballons was die mini
grenzen
das uns komplett weg lief ja und wo ich
mich tätigung vielen so eine analogie
würdigte
alexandra aus dem dokumentarfilm alle
sagt sie habe im restlichen für den
alltag gelernt
sie sei selbstbewusster geworden
alexander r wünscht sich dass sich mehr
frauen trauern bisher ungewohntes sparte
ritz betrieben was wirklich zählt er die
vorteile hat sich für männer das ist für
frau ist viel mehr geld als frauen stand
aufgrund vom umfeld reaktionen bis in
eine männerdomäne zu machen die fehler
den solothurner filmtagen beweisen
frauen können sich in männerdomänen
behaupten sie können kämpfen und wie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da digitale währung normales kind
tagtäglich eröffnet das erste besonders
loses corona im zentrum wie sehr fehlt
die s 4
ja es waren wir natürlich extrem und das
war natürlich klar wir stehen also der
helfer im wohnzimmer wirklich auf die
feststellung dass er diese neue
kategorie für das beste erstlingswerk
visualisiert die kategorien darüber hat
die erstlings wechsel ich dir so am
herzen
es ist die zweite ausgabe als direktorin
für solothurn filmtag und spirituell
studios gab ich bin gefahren wie starke
führung schaffte der schweiz ist so
unglaublich begeistert und denn herzige
vorbereitungs monate dazu beitragen dass
man als junger film schaffte und deshalb
weil der bis gründet also die sparte
opera prima ganz besondere kategorie mit
ihrem herzen liegt was ist jeder mal
stufe fall biete einen einzelnen film
geschäft frauen das ist unglaublich als
starkes jungs film schafft vergeht in
der schweiz sehr sehr unterschiedliche
zugriffe sehr unterschiedliche
handschriften und wenn hätte es eine
anzeige und sogar nachmachen und eine
prise schrieben dass du da bist du musst
hervorzuheben ja gestern sticks und
einen salto und die wichtigsten preise
verliehen wurde mir hans wichtigste für
sie im überblick
[Musik]
die preisverleihung der solothurner
filmtage war dieses jahr alles andere
als normal
kein publikum nur die gewinner in einem
leeren studie trotz allem die freude war
groß auch bei andreas tacke der
gewinnerin des prix soll in dieser zeit
jetzt hilft dieser preis mir auch dass
ich für eine weile finanziell unabhängig
weiter schreiben kann und das bedeutet
mir sehr viel
messen
[Musik]
in ihrem szenario sind es kleine
alltägliche momente die einer frau
zeigen dass es nicht so weitergehen kann
es wird er bald klar sie musste enge der
familie entkommen
[Musik]
sie trifft auf einen gastarbeiter der
ihr die tür öffnet um aus ihrem
familiären gefängnis auszubrechen
die sehnsucht nach freiheit ist groß
[Musik]
der zwang der konventionen ebenso
am ende hat sie ein kleines stück
freiheit erlangt
doch bleibt sie verhandeln im geflecht
der familie
ein starker film über große themen wie
schicksal befreiung und der wille nach
etwas autonomie
[Musik]
auch beim preis für das beste
erstlingswerk geht es um schicksale und
wie man damit umgehen kann
der film von fischen und menschen
handelt von der forellen züchterin
judith die mit ihrer tochter und helfer
gabriel auf einem hof lebt
doch bei einem überfall auf eine nahe
gelegene tankstelle kommt ihre tochter
ums leben
ein unvorstellbarer verlust
[Applaus]
doch es wird noch schlimmer als die
mutter erkennt wer der täter war ein
beklemmendes erstlingswerk über die
frage von schuld und wie weit man
vergeben kann
stefanie klemm herzlichen glückwunsch
für diesen ersten opera prima in der
geschichte der satire
[Applaus]
dieser preis sagt mir auch hey das ist
teamwork und wir haben das alle super
gemacht und ich glaube wir haben unser
bestes gegeben und ja es ist wirklich
für mich extrem wichtig danke vielmals
trotz virtuellem festival durfte auch
das publikum ihre favoriten wählen
der film erzählt das coming out eines
jungen türken hin und hergerissen
zwischen seiner sehnsucht und seiner
kultur
eigentlich ist eine cousine für ihn
vorgesehen
doch als er seine liebe zu einem mann
eingesteht kommt das zu mir klar
er beugt sich dem druck und heiratet
seine kate
nur seien echte liebe will er nicht
unterdrücken
ja das ist ne brands tag in seriöser
biete das klassische drama über
konventionen und welche hürden man
nehmen muss und sie zu überwinden hat
dem publikum am besten gefallen
ja und jetzt freuen wir uns natürlich
dass sie hier sind die gewinner des
publikumspreises gratulation und louis
materie hat die roten einen großen
nutzen unserer seite in diesem
kastrieren studio zu keiner zeit
minister so aber nichtsdestotrotz
gratulation
[Musik]
mit welchem zweck kinos ist im kino im
hochbau hat sich das wohnzimmer sättigen
erinnert das heimkino jetzt ganz ganz
viele ist das programm verfolgen und
andere studios renault im krankenhaus
filmstudio jegliche zum baubeginn war
nämlich im kinosaal traurigen in
solothurn der toner in der direktion
aber auch im programm es gibt unter
anderem große retrospektive über
schweizer film pionierinnen das ja steht
das im kontext mit 50 jahre
frauenstimmrecht nämlich ja absolut
natürlich das jubiläum und wie stark
ausgeprägt was ist passiert sein dasein
zwischen den zähnen 70 zum
frauenstimmrecht und 181 artikel wochen
und mixi das war wirklich sehr aktiv
sind sie aber sehr hier oben ist er
wirklich gekannt verändern sie die als
kämpferin aus voll kranken von der
solothurner filmtage was wünscht du dir
viel zukunft ja ich habe natürlich vor
allem dass man im jahr wieder hier
anstatt sich in den kinos und natürlich
heute besser als vorher und nachher
der film wird gespräch und ja das war
offentlich monat wieder öffnen lange
hier
das hoffe ich auch für ios alle danke
vielmals fertig spricht wie der
spaziergang hinterhof
ja wir haben es vorhin angesprochen dass
schweizer frauenstimmrecht wird 50 und
zwar nächste woche wir werden
ausführlich darüber berichten heute
zeigen ihnen dazu einige filmische
perlen aus solothurn
[Musik]
solothurn würdigt große pionierinnen wie
antonio gertrud pinkus und tula rohr in
einem spezialprogramm werden zehn filme
von schweizerinnen gezeigt die in den
zehn jahren nach einführung des
frauenstimmrechts geschichte schrieben
[Musik]
cholera ist eine schweizer vorkämpferin
des feministischen films 1993 schoss sie
mit ihrer doku eine andere geschichte
ein wichtiges zeitdokument
[Musik]
im film erzählen zeitzeugen von ihrem
kampf für gleichberechtigung arbeitslose
profitieren wird und wieso solle bezahlt
sie in frage
die trilogie fokussiert auf die jahre
zwischen 1910 und 1991
sie streiken sie gründen
genossenschaften und damit der
jährlichen fackel demo zeigen sie wie
sehr sie fürs frauenstimmrecht brennen
wie uns filmemacherin to la rua im web
interview verriet war es für sie
selbstverständlich dass nur frauen dies
erzählen können
normalerweise schreibe männer und männer
für ihre skis oder und jetzt geht sein
promoter moment gebe es regeln ihre mal
über unsere geschichte und diese heiße
auto film eine andere geschichte werden
in ein anderes schiff mir hän für die
ideen fehlen mir einfach die schwelle
für zähle neben alten dokumentationen
über das frauenstimmrecht laufen in
solothurn auch neue filme die sich mit
dem thema beschäftigen
durak wie sie in europa lahm edition
demi lovato ist eine historische doku
die zeigt wie konsequent die männer den
frauen das stimmrecht an der ohne
verwehrt haben über 50 abstimmungen und
immer dieselbe antwort
vor allem die minderwertigkeitskomplexe
der frauen schockieren aus heutiger
sicht
[Musik]
das drama die göttliche ordnung dass
solothurn 2017 eröffnete ist bis heute
der einzige spielfilm über das
helvetische frauenstimmrecht für das
drehbuch erhielt petra volpe damals den
schweizer filmpreis
trotzdem sei es für frauen in der
filmbranche immer noch schwierig
projekte zu realisieren studie kollege
aus mit ihrer karriere darf die
renommierte schweizer regisseurin to la
rua mehr als zufrieden sein
aber mit der gleichstellung in ihrem
heimatland ist sie nicht glücklich sehr
sehr wenig gleichstellung zum beispiel
nicht einfach prinzipiell vom 1
das ist noch weit weg immerhin bei den
solothurner filmtagen sind die frauen
gut vertreten über die hälfte der
nominierten produktionen wurden von
regisseurinnen gedreht
[Musik]
das war unser ausflug zu den solothurner
filmtagen nächste woche da machen wir
station in bern und ich freue mich auf
die begegnung mit der schauspielerin und
parodistin birgit steinegger schönen sie
auf bahn wieder mit dabei sind gleich
jetzt folgt auf sf1 die serie meine
geniale freundin bis bald
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
des wissens
[Applaus]